all right let's hear from a few more
people in our audience we take calls
weekly via Discord you can find our
Discord at davidpackman.com
slash Discord that is the place to go
let's try JoJo from Melbourne Australia
which can sometimes go well sometimes
JoJo's calls get a little risque JoJo
what's on your mind today
uh I uh
um
Jojo
hello hello JoJo did you have a question
for me today oh yeah are you can you
hear me yes
hi hi David uh I do have a question for
you yes um
uh okay I'm going to talk about nepotism
did you see the uh wave of it coming
uh did you think it was abnormal
um so obviously first of all there was
the
family that took over the White House
and then
there's uh Clarence Thomas and his wife
um this is nothing like
I would have seen in my country anyway
but is did you think there was a
abnormal or was it just something that
I think nepotism in the Trump
Administration was particularly Brazen
but not altogether surprising
yeah I mean I thought it was in
particular but then it just capped it
off with the Judy Thomas and uh Clarence
Thomas theme which I think I mean in a
normal
world I would think that he would uh
resign his place in the Supreme Court
but that's just me I'm not sure yeah I
don't know what the Clarence Thomas
thing is necessarily nepotism I think
it's more uh corruption you know and uh
yeah I don't know that nepotism is the
word I would apply but it's certainly
disgusting that's for sure
oh absolutely well in that parties are
not not necessarily but um a what do you
call it um
what is it uh
well it's certainly corruption inside of
trading I don't know are you interested
in a trivia question can I give you a
trivia question
absolutely can you name countries that
start with the letter j
um countries uh
oh my God you put me in the spot
um
uh
can you give me another letter well
that's the letter I have JoJo listen
I've got a whole bunch of people here I
do have to move on
Johannesburg is a city Johannesburg is a
city no I know it is I know I'm really
good at um geography please give me
another letter one that's the only
letter I have Jojo I have to let you go
I apologize
um all right JoJo okay here he is JoJo
from Melbourne Australia very much
appreciated would have accepted Japan
would have accepted Jamaica and would
have accepted Jordan as well all would
have been acceptable let's go to Shelley
from Indiana Shelly welcome to the
program what can I do for you today
I'm doing well
okay great uh uh so I
don't know the governmental programs and
how we have
so many people that disapprove of them
and I was wondering if the left maybe
took more
um the approach of what the swedens do
where they offer programs to everyone no
matter the no matter what the income
level is that way more people would be
on board with it and that it would help
people you're saying eliminate means
testing and then maybe there would be
less opposition to social welfare
programs in the United States if
everybody just got them
right exactly so obviously there would
be like people on the lower and would
get more benefits but if if the people
that made more money felt like they were
still getting something out of it then
it wouldn't be the blind pain into it
and I'm not getting anything from it I
totally understand the idea
I don't think it would make a big
difference to many Republicans
unfortunately I think with some it would
but I think with many it would not
well and the reason why
why I thought that it might be a good
idea is because when when they were
doing the stimulus checks and there was
more you know people on the higher end
that were still getting you saw people
that that weren't really wouldn't
normally approve of those programs right
I'm happy to get it and so it's like
well maybe if we expanded this where
people felt like they were still getting
something out of it yeah
I don't know it was just a thought it's
an idea I think it would do a little I
don't think it would make a big
difference that's my instinct
yeah how are things in Indiana things
are okay there you're you're welcoming
back Mike Pence and everything
uh I'm sure they uh I'm not stupid but
um the weather is really good so that's
good yeah good Shelly I appreciate the
call
all right thank you so much so much all
right Shelly from Indiana always great
to hear from her when you're busy during
the day and you need a quick snack
sometimes you're just in the mood for
something sweet that's when I reach for
monk pack our sponsor monk pack offers
gooey granola bars that melt in your
mouth as well as nut and Seed bars that
are perfectly crunchy sweet and salty
but the best part is that each bar is
plant-based with only one gram of sugar
two to three net carbs and only about
150 calories it's great if you're doing
keto or low carb or like me you just
want to minimize your sugar intake I
can't get enough of dark chocolate cocoa
I am just a chocolate guy it's great but
they come in other flavors too like sea
salt dark chocolate caramel sea salt
they just launched peanut butter cocoa
chip and dark chocolate cocoa if you
don't love monk pack as much as our
entire team does monk pack will give you
your money back go try monk pack keto
granola bars and nut and Seed bars go to
monkpak.com and use the code Pacman for
20 off the link is down below